the first time i seen a basketball i
think it was out the womb i have baby
pictures holding a basketball it's
something that's been a part of my life
for my whole life
[Music]
my generations it's kind of been passed
down starting with my grandpa you know
he played semi-pro
and then my father
had a career a short time in the nba but
mostly overseas and i had a chance to
visit him out there and see his
lifestyle and playing basketball and
see how much the ball did for him and
you know the different places it took
him in the world and how it changed his
life and you know my ultimate dream was
to be in the nba
it was kind of like a stepped process to
where
initially i wanted to be on the varsity
basketball team didn't move to i wanted
to play in college for free get a free
education and once i was in college
that's when i was like i want to make
this my lifestyle of making my life
sacrifice a lot of childhood you know a
lot of hard work goes into it i moved a
lot i traveled a lot you know and i was
away from my family and friends for a
lot of time
all in pursuit to
get to where i'm at now and you know
still a long way to go
i just want to continue to grow in all
aspects of life and set myself up for
after basketball i'm actually a part
owner in a beverage right now called
coco5 i'm three years into my charity
and my foundation is called the devin
booker starting five
and
book projects is my creative brand
studio
[Music]
some advice that kobe left me with just
be legendary
you know that that's what it's about
legacy and inspiring
i think that's the biggest thing you can
do is inspire the next generations and
you know that's not always
making a money commitment you know it's
the way you carry yourself also so
you know just understanding that you
know it's bigger than you and you know
there's a lot of people watching you
when you're on this stage and you're in
this position